Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
"L'identité et le territoire".
Il y a Paris et la province,
deux entités
en rivalité d'influence,
deux développements économiques,
et pour savoir
où il fait meilleur vivre,
il y a la Normandie et la Bretagne,
l'Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes
et l'Occitanie
et d'autres grandes régions
dont l'individualité profonde
anthropologique et socio-culturelle
est en constante évolution,
parfois avec des regroupements
sans cohérence territoriale
ou économique.
La mondialisation a rebattu
les cartes du village planétaire,
avec le télétravail,
les mobilités découlant
de la transition énergétique
et de la révolution numérique,
avec aussi des services publics
plus ou moins performants,
des trappes résidentielles
et des trappes scolaires.
La montée des communautarismes,
des replis identitaires
et des violences,
des révoltes qui se propagent,
- on se souvient
des bonnets rouges et,
plus récemment, des gilets jaunes -,
sur fond d'inégalités sociales
et de désindustrialisation
des territoires.
Tout cela contribue
à faire émerger
des revendications identitaires
liées à la proximité et la distance,
les traditions et la modernité,
la religion et les migrants,
les moeurs et jusqu'au vote,
qui prend
un caractère anthropologique.
Un véritable archipel des identités
que nous allons chercher
à discerner avec mes invités,
que je vous présente.
Hélène Peskine,
vous êtes architecte, urbaniste,
secrétaire général du PUCA.
Jean-Pierre Lecoq,
vous êtes maire
du 6e arrondissement de Paris.
Eric Piolle,
vous êtes maire de Grenoble
et nous vous avons
en visioconférence.
Juliette Méadel,
vous êtes femme
politique, ancien ministre.
Jacques Lévy,
vous êtes
universitaire et géographe.
Il y a Paris et la province.
Au-delà
de cette évidence géographique,
qu'est-ce qui les distingue
en termes généraux ?
On va rentrer dans le détail,
mais si vous avez
un point de discrimination
entre Paris et la province,
c'est lequel, Jean-Pierre Lecoq ?
Je rappelle que vous êtes
maire du 6e arrondissement, à Paris.
-Et conseiller régional
d'Ile-de-France.
Je ne confonds pas
le 6e arrondissement
avec l'Ile-de-France,
voire avec la province.
-Ca reste un bel arrondissement.
-Oui, ça reste l'arrondissement
du Sénat et du jardin du Luxembourg,
mais c'est un arrondissement
pétri d'histoire.
Je suis aussi originaire de l'Aisne,
à 100 km de Paris,
un département rural,
qui était en même temps industriel
et qui ne l'est plus.
Tous les clignotants sociaux
sont au rouge, dans l'Aisne.
-Oui, mais sur Paris ?
Qu'est-ce qui les distingue ?
-C'est de plus en plus notable,
si vous voulez,
c'est un éloignement
de nos compatriotes de province
des services publics.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a eu
cette révolte des gilets jaunes
et la raison pour laquelle
on a le sentiment
que le gouvernement
est attentif aux revendications
qui peuvent naître
du fait, notamment,
de la hausse du coût de l'énergie
et des prix de l'essence.
En province,
on a souvent
besoin de sa voiture.
On a quelquefois même
besoin de deux voitures,
alors qu'à Paris,
on peut circuler à vélo.
Tous les Parisiens
et Parisiennes ne le peuvent pas.
-Eric Piolle, vous,
je suis désolé,
vous êtes à la fois à Paris
et en province,
mais disons que, pour nous,
vous êtes M. Province
au cours de cette émission.
Qu'est-ce qui distingue, pour vous,
en termes très généraux,
Paris et la province ?
*-C'est la concentration
des centres de pouvoir
qui est à Paris.
Il y a une consanguinité
de ces centres de pouvoir.
Rien que la façon dont vous décrivez
Paris et la province...
Nous, on ne se vit pas en province.
On ne se vit pas parisien,
mais c'est évident
qu'à Grenoble,
on ne se vit pas pareil
que quand on est à Bordeaux,
dans mes Pyrénées natales,
que quand on est dans le Nord.
Donc, la province,
il n'y a que vous qui en parlez.
Le reste du pays
vit différemment
et vit une concentration
des pouvoirs
et des centres de décision
à Paris.
-Quand on vous demande,
Eric Piolle, en trois mots,
de vous définir, vous dites quoi ?
*-On ne se définit pas
comme provinciaux.
-Vous vous définissez
comme grenoblois ?
*-On n'a pas de problème
de service public en province.
Il y a des bassins urbains
qui ont tous les services publics
de la terre
et il y a
des zones périphériques, rurales,
qui ont des problèmes de connexion,
de mobilité,
de connexion numérique,
de connexion aux services publics.
Nous nous définissons...
Aujourd'hui, à Grenoble,
on se définit comme grenoblois
quand on vit dans un bassin
de 700 000 habitants,
on se définit comme montagnards
parce qu'on est là
au coeur des Alpes.
C'est ça qui fait notre identité.
Mais on ne se définit pas trop
par notre identité
et plus par ce que l'on fait.
Mais pour parler
de mes racines basco-béarnaises,
quand je suis chez moi,
- je vais être dans mon village
pour les fêtes de Noël -,
là, on va se définir tout autrement.
On se définit par les racines
parce qu'on est notre essence
et notre histoire
et moins par ce que l'on fait.
C'est un autre rapport
au territoire qui est
totalement différent
de celui qu'on vit à Grenoble
ou à Paris.
-Très bien.
On va essayer d'entrer
dans le détail.
Selon le sociologue Pierre Bourdieu,
la province peut être définie
par la distance sociale,
économique et culturelle
avec Paris,
qui brille de mille feux.
Est-ce que, à votre avis,
Hélène Peskine,
ce retard a été rattrapé ?
Inversement,
est-ce que Paris n'est pas
pénalisé par la désindustrialisation
qui est en cours
depuis plusieurs décennies ?
-Je dirais qu'il y a plusieurs Paris
dans votre Paris.
Paris, c'est à la fois la France,
c'est la ville-capitale qui,
d'une certaine manière,
est assimilée à la France,
et puis il y a le territoire
parisien et francilien.
Ca a été évoqué.
L'Ile-de-France n'est pas Paris.
Quand on regarde,
à l'échelle de la région,
l'influence de l'aire
métropolitaine de Paris,
on a des différences
sociales fortes,
de la proche banlieue
jusqu'à la très lointaine
périphérie urbaine.
Il y a peut-être à distinguer
de quel Paris on parle.
On a cette espèce d'image
du Paris des élites,
un Paris sociologique,
qui est celui
qui est réfuté par un certain nombre
de territoires en région,
qui disent :
"On a la capacité
de faire centralité,
"d'avoir des services à proximité,
"d'avoir de grandes
fonctions internationales."
C'est à une dimension moindre
qu'à Paris,
mais ça existe ailleurs
en France, bien entendu,
et de manière différenciée
qu'on soit à Bordeaux, Lille,
Toulouse ou Marseille.
Il y a le Paris vécu des Parisiens,
les élus ici
en parleront mieux que moi,
d'une réalité territoriale
avec des difficultés sociales
et spatiales
qui se révèle au quotidien
et qui est disjoint
de ce Paris des élites
et du centre de décision,
qui est une réalité aussi,
qui peut donner l'impression
à une partie des Français
que les décisions sont
prises hors sol
et dans une espèce
de sphère politique
médiatico-institutionnelle
qui est dans l'entre-soi,
parce que c'est la concentration
de tous les pouvoirs.
-Paris-province, Juliette Méadel ?
Vous, vous êtes à la fois
de Paris et de banlieue
puisque vous êtes parisienne
et élue de Montrouge.
Quelle distinction vous faites ?
Est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que,
quand vous traversez
le périphérique,
vous n'êtes plus dans Paris ?
-Oui complètement.
Ca peut vous paraître bizarre,
Montrouge est une commune
limitrophe de Paris,
et quand je traverse le périph,
c'est pas pareil.
Il faut dire que Paris
concentre une incroyable quantité
de richesses et de pouvoir et que,
de ce fait, vous avez quand même
des services publics
en termes d'offre sanitaire,
en termes d'offre scolaire,
en termes de transport,
en termes d'accès, même,
à la sécurité,
puisque vous avez un nombre
de policiers,
grâce à la préfecture de police,
qui est plus important
que dans n'importe
quelle autre ville.
Paris concentre quand même
un accès à un service
public confortable.
Paris et la région Ile-de-France
concentrent l'essentiel
des plus gros sièges d'entreprises,
ont un réseau
de transport important.
Du point de vue du citoyen,
je comprends le citoyen
qui vit dans une ville,
quelle qu'elle soit,
et qui se dit
- et à Montrouge, nous le vivons :
"Quand même, c'est pas pareil."
Sur ce qu'on appelle
le périscolaire,
il y a plus d'argent
à Paris.
Les enfants qui vont
à l'école à Paris,
ils ont plus d'argent,
il y a plus d'activités scolaires.
-On va entrer
dans le détail.
-C'est la différence :
la concentration de richesses.
-Jacques Lévy,
vous qui connaissez
ces questions
de justice spatiale,
est-ce qu'il y a une injustice
spatiale entre Paris
et le reste de la France ?
-Il y en a une,
elle est au détriment de Paris,
c'est-à-dire de l'Ile-de-France.
Quand je dis Paris,
je veux dire l'aire urbaine
de Paris,
y compris, à certains égards,
de Paris intra-muros,
qui concentre autant de pauvres
que l'ensemble des pauvres
qui se trouvent
en dehors des aires urbaines,
sur une immense surface.
En valeur absolue,
il n'y en a pas plus que dans Paris.
C'est-à-dire que les grandes
villes en général
concentrent à la fois
la richesse et la pauvreté,
et c'est particulièrement
le cas en France pour Paris.
Quand je dis Paris,
je veux dire
l'aire urbaine de Paris,
c'est-à-dire
13 millions d'habitants.
Paris intra-muros,
c'est quelques quartiers
de la métropole,
pour qu'on se comprenne bien.
Donc en fait,
l'Ile-de-France,
qui correspond à peu près
à cette aire urbaine,
un petit peu moins,
avec 12 million d'habitants,
elle produit 700 milliards par an
de PIB,
donc plus de 30 %
de la production nationale,
mais une fois que tous
les prélèvements sont faits,
en fait, elle n'est plus, à peine,
qu'au niveau de sa part
dans la population active.
Toute la surproductivité
de ce qui est, en effet,
plus concentré en Ile-de-France,
toutes les professions
qu'on dit créatives...
-Oui, mais vous n'êtes pas...
-Tout ça disparaît,
en fait,
pas la grosse machine
opaque de redistribution
qui fait que, en gros,
en plus, le prix du foncier
est particulièrement élevé,
ce qui est logique
dans une grande ville,
quand vous êtes fonctionnaire,
par exemple,
petit fonctionnaire à Paris,
quand vous gagnez à peu près
la même chose
que si vous étiez
dans une petite ville,
vous êtes plus pauvre.
Le niveau de pauvreté est aussi
plus élevé, plus fort à Paris
et en Ile-de-France.
Si on regarde
les chiffres globaux,
en fait, les Franciliens
sont plutôt plus pauvres
que la moyenne de la France
de la métropole,
alors qu'ils produisent
beaucoup plus.
Il y a une injustice.
-Jean-Pierre Lecoq,
vous êtes d'accord ?
-Oui.
Je suis d'accord.
Il y a un problème
pour tous les agents
de catégorie C qui sont...
-Qu'est-ce que c'est, catégorie C ?
-Les agents d'exécution.
Un cadre A dirige,
un cadre B assiste le cadre A
et un cadre C,
un agent de catégorie C, exécute.
Par définition,
ce sont des gens qu'on a glorifiés
au moment de la pandémie.
Le télétravail leur est impossible.
Je rappelle que 80 %
à 90 % des postes
en collectivité territoriale
ne sont pas télétravaillables.
Agent des services
de traitement des ordures,
auxiliaire de puéricultrice...
Ces gens-là ont donné
beaucoup d'eux-mêmes,
ils habitent maintenant,
avec l'élévation
du prix du foncier à Paris...
Le prix du mètre carré
a doublé en 15 ans.
Ca a été la même chose
pour les loyers.
Ca s'étend à la première
et à la deuxième couronnes.
Ca s'étend à toute la zone dense.
C'est l'ancien département
de la Seine,
7 millions d'habitants.
Ces gens-là qui gagnent
ou le SMIC ou légèrement au-dessus,
ils habitent à 40 ou 50 km de Paris,
voire dans l'Oise, dans l'Aisne,
ils sont soumis aux aléas
des transports en commun,
pas besoin de développer,
et après 15 ans
ou 25 ans,
ils sont usés.
Donc, un taux
de 15 % actuellement,
de 12 % à 15 %
du personnel municipal parisien
qui est en arrêt maladie
ou en difficulté.
C'est pas étonnant.
Je ne dénonce personne.
Il faut que Paris
loge beaucoup plus
ceux et celles
qui travaillent pour les Parisiens.
-On va essayer...
-C'est le cas de beaucoup
de communes...
-On va essayer d'aller
un peu plus loin
et de voir ce que représente
l'attachement d'un territoire
pour ses citoyens.
On a une carte.
C'est le baromètre
de l'attachement à sa région.
Durant la pandémie de Covid,
des milliers de Parisiens
sont allés en province
"pour se mettre aux abris",
selon la formule,
mais aussi par désaffection
pour Paris.
Est-il exact, M. Piolle,
que renaît, pardon,
une nouvelle fierté régionale ?
A contrario,
comme vous l'avez entendu,
moins d'attractivité
pour les grandes métropoles,
et notamment Paris ?
Vous nous direz
ce qui vous attache à votre région.
Il y a des régions
auxquelles on est plus attaché,
par exemple la Bretagne,
et beaucoup moins,
par exemple la région PACA.
Peut-être que vous nous direz,
dans votre cas, Rhône-Alpes,
ce qui fait que vous êtes attaché
à cette région,
et un commentaire là-dessus.
*-Je peux commencer par ça.
D'abord, Rhône-Alpes,
c'est très grand.
Aujourd'hui, Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes,
ça va d'Aurillac à Thonon-les-Bains.
Il faut 8 heures de voiture
pour traverser Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes.
La région administrative
telle que vous l'entendez
n'a plus de sens,
ni en termes de culture historique,
ni en termes de proximité
de modes de vie.
Ce qui m'attache,
pourquoi je suis arrivé ici,
à 20 ans, depuis mes Pyrénées
et qui y suis resté,
c'est évidemment les montagnes.
Très attaché aux montagnes
et à une taille de ville,
qui permet à la fois
un bouillonnement, une innovation,
une capacité à mélanger les gens
et une richesse, voilà,
de vie culturelle,
de vie économique.
J'ai travaillé 18 ans
dans l'industrie.
Ici, on peut travailler longtemps,
changer d'entreprise,
continuer à évoluer.
C'est ça qui m'attache à la terre :
à la fois l'environnement,
la montagne,
et cette capacité à se mélanger
dans une taille qui permet
des déplacements forts.
Les Parisiens,
ils viennent pas depuis Paris
dans des endroits
qui restent du monde urbain
mais qui sont éloignés.
Nous, on est à 3 heures de TGV,
un petit peu moins, de Paris.
C'est trop loin pour aller
travailler tous les jours.
On peut y aller
toutes les semaines,
mais tous les jours,
c'est compliqué.
On n'a pas été envahis de Parisiens.
Il n'y a pas de résidence
secondaire ici, assez peu.
Par contre,
on a vu, effectivement,
depuis Grenoble-Centre,
des gens qui ont cherché
à retrouver un contact
avec la nature
et qui ont acheté des maisons
à l'extérieur.
-Est-ce que vous constatez ça,
au PUCA,
dans le laboratoire
que vous animez,
Hélène Peskine,
cet attachement à,
on doit dire la province,
puisque c'est un terme générique,
et avec une désaffection
pour Paris.
-C'est vrai et pas vrai.
Paris est toujours
la métropole-capitale
et continue d'attirer beaucoup,
notamment de jeunes actifs,
des étudiants, des jeunes actifs
et de jeunes ménages
au début de leur vie familiale.
La difficulté qu'a soulevée
Jean-Pierre Lecoq,
c'est que, au bout d'un moment,
on est coincé par sa capacité
de pouvoir d'achat
et d'accès au logement.
Il y a un grand nombre de Parisiens,
arrivés à l'âge du premier,
du deuxième ou du troisième enfant,
qui se desserrent
de la ville-centre
et qui perdent de cette qualité
de vie d'accès aux services,
à la culture, à l'emploi
dont ils pouvaient bénéficier,
au bénéfice d'un logement adapté
à leur réalité familiale.
On a à la fois un effet d'attraction
et un effet de répulsion.
D'après les travaux qu'on a conduits
sur les effets du Covid
sur les migrations résidentielles,
il n'y a pas d'exode massif
des villes vers les campagnes.
C'est une vue de l'esprit,
ou de certaines
catégories professionnelles,
notamment les professions libérales,
qui ont fait ce saut d'aller habiter
dans leur résidence secondaire
pendant la crise
et qui y sont restés.
Par contre, on a un effet
de desserrement, je dirais,
en cascade
depuis les grandes villes,
dont les métropoles régionales,
vers leur périphérie,
voire vers des villes moyennes,
et des villes moyennes
vers des petites villes,
avec la réflexion :
"Je veux être plus près
de la nature, d'un environnement
"qui est serein
après la crise qu'on a traversée."
C'est un effet en cascade.
Les Parisiens
ont pu quitter,
relativement nombreux,
- pour Paris, c'est significatif -
le centre-ville
pour aller vers Bordeaux
ou vers Grenoble,
ou vers Marseille, ou vers Nice,
et pas vers le village
de 40 habitants où on va
refaire sa vie sous une forme
plus marginale
et proche de la nature.
En revanche,
dans chaque strate territoriale,
on a un phénomène de rejet
de la vie quotidienne qu'on a eue
pendant le confinement,
qui a été violente,
et on cherche ailleurs,
dans la strate
démographique inférieure.
-M. Lecoq,
puisque personne défend Paris,
je pensais que vous le feriez.
Mais est-ce que vous pouvez dire
si Paris s'est dégradé
ces dernières décennies ?
Est-ce que Paris
a perdu en attractivité ?
Sur le plan culturel,
on le constate pas.
Les grandes expositions
se font à Paris,
les grands événements culturels
se font également à Paris.
Est-ce qu'il y a concrètement
une perte d'attractivité ?
Où vous la situez ?
-Je vais répondre de façon aussi
mesurée qu'Hélène Peskine.
Elle a eu raison...
-Soyez moins mesuré
et dites ce que vous pensez.
-Je vais le dire,
mais je vais avoir
une réponse politique.
Effectivement,
j'ajoute que Paris reste
également excessivement attractif
pour les étrangers.
Il y en a énormément,
d'où le phénomène
de résidences secondaires
qu'on retrouve notamment
dans l'ouest parisien.
Après, le problème,
c'était déjà le cas,
la fuite des familles
après un ou deux enfants,
c'est-à-dire, d'ailleurs...
Vous aviez,
des arrondissements centraux
vers les périphériques,
puis de la périphérie
vers les premières couronnes,
le Covid a accéléré ça...
Il semblerait qu'il y ait
à nouveau un certain retour à Paris.
Ce qui est très fort sur Paris,
c'est le cas, bien évidemment,
du 6e arrondissement,
c'est la qualité des écoles
et des universités.
Ca, on l'ôtera jamais à Paris.
Ca, c'est très fort.
En revanche, il est clair
que vous avez des gens qui,
maintenant,
considèrent que l'espace
public parisien
n'est pas au niveau
où il devrait être :
propreté, sécurité...
A la veille des Jeux Olympiques,
et alors que Paris reste
une destination
touristique importante,
les Asiatiques n'étant
pas encore revenus,
j'attire l'attention
des responsables sur la sécurité.
On ne peut pas continuer
à faire venir des touristes
qui se font voler leur montre,
voire tabasser,
entre Roissy
et le centre de la capitale.
Ca, si vous voulez,
c'est relayé dans le monde entier.
Donc, il y a un problème,
effectivement :
la mairie de Paris,
la ville de Paris, les élus
de Paris et de la métropole doivent
se concentrer sur la qualité
de l'espace public.
J'ajoute enfin que,
après la Covid,
Paris est considéré
par beaucoup de Parisiens,
et ça conduit également
à leur départ de la capitale,
comme une ville très dense.
On va voir, maintenant,
un débat excessivement important,
au printemps prochain,
sur le PLU,
le plan local d'urbanisme.
Je plaide maintenant pour un Paris
où il n'y aurait plus
d'accroissement de la densité.
Les Parisiens, après la Covid,
veulent effectivement respirer
un meilleur air
et également avoir un environnement
qui soit plus agréable.
-Votre point de vue,
Juliette Méadel,
en tant que transfrontière ?
Comment vous appréciez
cette dégradation dont parle
Jean-Pierre Lecoq ?
-Je serai pas aussi négative
que vous,
c'est-à-dire que je crois
que chaque ville
a sa particularité, son histoire,
et elle est dépendante
de la personnalité de son maire.
Ce que je trouve, moi,
qui s'est beaucoup dégradé à Paris,
c'est propre à son attractivité,
vous l'avez dit,
c'est l'incapacité
de la mairie actuelle
à gérer les flux importants
de tourisme,
à gérer la question des transports.
En dépit des pistes cyclables,
qui ont amené du bon
dans la vie quotidienne,
il y a toujours
énormément d'embouteillages,
des cars
avec énormément de touristes
et sans contrôle
des entrées et des sorties.
Je considère qu'il faudrait
prendre des mesures
pour installer
des quotas de tourisme.
C'est comme à Venise :
à Venise,
on a une surconsommation touristique
qui dégrade des bâtiments.
On a un patrimoine exceptionnel,
à Paris, qui se dégrade.
Il y a à la fois
une forte attractivité
et des mesures qui sont pas prises
pour protéger la ville.
Niveau services publics,
je suis plus nuancée que vous,
monsieur le maire.
Il y a quand même, à Paris,
des offres
de qualité exceptionnelle.
Il y a de très grands lycées
parisiens qui restent au top,
il y a de grands hôpitaux.
Je pense à Necker, à Debré.
Il y a des spécialisations
avec du top niveau.
Il y a de grandes universités
plus largement que dans Paris.
On a... Ce qui fait
la réussite de la France,
on le trouve quand même,
aussi et encore, toujours, à Paris
et en Ile-de-France.
Ce qui, à mon avis,
fait le plus défaut,
c'est cette capacité à élever
le niveau moyen
de services publics pour tous.
Paris, c'est aussi
la ville des contrastes,
c'est la ville
qui a le gouvernement,
le Parlement,
les grandes sociétés du CAC 40,
c'est la ville
qui concentre la richesse,
mais le niveau moyen de services
publics n'est pas le même pour tous.
C'est dans cette direction
que devrait travailler la mairie.
-Jacques Lévy ?
-C'est la ville des pouvoirs,
sauf des Franciliens.
En fait,
il y a une malédiction
de l'auto-gouvernement
des Parisiens depuis très longtemps,
notamment depuis la IIIe République,
où l'accord entre les notables
ruraux et l'Etat central,
c'était de priver les grandes villes
d'un véritable gouvernement,
avec plusieurs dispositifs
constitutionnels
qui ont bien joué leur rôle.
Ca s'est amélioré
pour les grandes villes
autres que Paris.
J'utilise pas
la notion de "province" :
désormais, justement,
l'espace hors de Paris
s'est différencié avec des villes
comme Grenoble.
Les grandes villes
où il y a des nuances,
mais ce sont plus des gradients
qui les distinguent de Paris
et qui les distinguent encore plus
de leur propre environnement.
Le centre de Grenoble
est plus proche de Paris
que des endroits les plus reculés
d'Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes.
Ca, c'est vrai, mais en revanche,
la gouvernance à Paris,
elle s'est dégradée.
Alors que l'organisation
en métropole a permis
des gouvernements urbains
un peu trop petits à l'échelle
des agglomérations
plutôt que des aires urbaines,
c'est un problème,
mais il y a une légitimité,
notamment à Lyon,
où on élit directement
les conseillers
métropolitains,
mais à Paris, au contraire,
on a rajouté des couches et donc,
on a bien vu, d'ailleurs,
sous le mandat
de François Hollande :
on a vu une alliance
entre les maires des grandes
communes franciliennes,
le Sénat et l'Etat,
finalement l'Etat profond,
qui ne voulait pas
avoir un vrai pouvoir
car il serait important,
forcément,
pour une aire urbaine
de 13 millions d'habitants,
c'est la réalité.
Donc les Franciliens doivent-ils
être punis pour l'éternité
parce qu'ils habitent
une grande agglomération ?
Y a là un problème
et ça a des effets,
bien sûr,
sur la vie quotidienne.
-Laissons cela en suspens.
Alors, l'Hexagone est devenu
un archipel d'identités,
de communautés, de moeurs,
d'affiliations socio-culturelles,
certains parlent
de désaffiliation.
Est-ce que, monsieur Piolle,
vous voyez...
Comment vous arrivez à harmoniser,
puisqu'on vous a
quelquefois décrié,
de certains côtés
politiques,
comment vous arrivez
à harmoniser
une unité géographique
avec une unité politique,
socio-culturelle
et religieuse
pour faire quelque part identité,
identité territoriale,
identité régionale,
identité nationale ?
-Peut-être pour reprendre
votre question dans l'autre sens,
par rapport à votre introduction,
est-ce que la France
est devenue un archipel
où se sont différenciées
des identités
ou est-ce que c'est juste
qu'on a perdu, un petit peu,
de notre affiliation
à un projet commun ?
Parce que les différences
de modes de vie,
je le redis,
pour moi qui viens des frontières,
à la frontière espagnole,
d'un village à la limite du Béarn
et du Pays basque,
jamais la façon de vivre
de mon village n'a été similaire
à celle qui se pratiquait ici,
ça m'a fait un choc,
quand je suis arrivé,
un choc de mode de vie,
de façon de faire la fête,
de pratiques orales,
de pratiques économiques,
de pratiques culturelles,
donc j'ai eu ce choc
en arrivant là, à 20 ans,
et, en faisant mon tour de France,
à l'occasion de la présidentielle
pour la primaire des écologistes,
j'ai pu découvrir des différences
de modes de vie extrêmes.
Donc ces différences
ont toujours existé.
-Mais ce n'était pas
communautarisé,
si je puis dire.
-Ce qui manque,
maintenant,
c'est le sentiment d'adhésion
à un projet qui,
tout en nous laissant ancrés
dans nos communautés,
nous fédère à l'échelle nationale.
Et là, effectivement,
on a une désaffiliation,
qui est multiple, hein,
on voit cette France fracturée,
on l'a vu aux législatives,
évidemment,
avec des sous-préfectures
où on a massivement voté pour le RN
et ce monde urbain qui a voté
entre NUPES,
macronisme et LR,
mais y a vraiment
une France fracturée
qu'on retrouve aux législatives,
et puis, évidemment,
des phénomènes de repli,
avec aussi...
-Mais est-ce que vous direz
repli communautariste qui affecte
l'identité nationale ?
-Pour moi,
c'est l'identité nationale
qui est affectée
et c'est ça
qui vient, du coup,
nourrir d'autres formes
de connexions qui se renforcent.
Nous sommes des multi-appartenants
communautaires,
nous appartenons
à différentes communautés,
mais si notre lien se réduit
avec le projet national,
avec un projet qui nous dépasse,
alors, effectivement,
y a le risque qu'une
de nos communautés locales,
tout d'un coup,
prenne trop de place.
Donc y a évidemment le phénomène
de communautarisme religieux
d'un islam politique,
qui pousse et qui déborde
le cadre spirituel pour essayer
d'aller sur les modes de vie,
la culture et la politique,
mais y a aussi d'autres
replis identitaires,
des replis de catégories
socio-professionnelles, hein,
les plus riches
qui se replient aussi
et qui vivent dans un monde
toujours plus séparé,
avec des inégalités
qui grandissent, donc là,
ça manque d'élan national.
-Vous-même,
comme édile local,
qu'est-ce que vous faites
pour ramener
à une cohésion nationale
toute cette disparité
communautariste ?
-Bah, il faut recréer...
-Parce qu'on vous a reproché,
à certains moments,
d'aller vers, comment dire,
des dissensions,
si vous voulez...
identitaires.
-Oh, non.
Y a un projet politique,
derrière,
c'est que je suis très scrupuleux
sur la loi de 1905,
je suis très respectueux
de cette loi qui me semble
être bonne en état.
Et certains, aujourd'hui,
comme le disait Aimé Césaire,
cherchent à jouer
avec les principes de la République
pour d'autres objets,
ils négocient avec les principes
de la République
pour discriminer tel ou tel
ou pour lutter politiquement,
et au lieu de lutter politiquement,
ils se servent
de nos textes fondamentaux
pour faire ces luttes politiques.
-On vous a entendu.
Alors, monsieur Lecoq,
vous pensez qu'il y a
une fragmentation
identitaire aujourd'hui
de la France,
communautariste ?
-C'est-à-dire que les communautés
ont toujours existé,
y avait des communautés
de territoire,
les provinciaux avaient...
Le Pays basque est une province
qui a beaucoup de traditions,
les Bretons, rappelez-vous,
qui arrivaient à Paris,
gare Montparnasse, eux-mêmes,
ils étaient perdus
et la Mission bretonne
créée à proximité de Montparnasse
était destinée justement à encadrer
les jeunes filles bretonnes
pour qu'elles ne soient pas happées
par la prostitution
aux portes de la gare
et qu'elles soient,
en quelque sorte...
Et ensuite,
c'était souvent
des nourrices
ou des servantes de grandes
familles bourgeoises.
-Mais c'était avant.
-C'était au 19e.
-Qui étaient discriminées
sous le nom de Bécassine.
-Bien sûr !
Après, on a connu
la discrimination
vis-à-vis des Italiens,
des Espagnols, etc.
-Mais aujourd'hui ?
-Maintenant,
les communautés musulmanes,
avec une forte adhésion
à la religion musulmane,
peuvent poser un véritable problème,
ça a été dit par Eric Piolle.
Lui a eu ce problème
de gestion d'une association
dans les piscines grenobloises,
il n'en a pas parlé directement,
mais je pense qu'il faut,
face à des tentatives
d'entrisme ou de séparatisme
de certaines communautés,
ou plutôt de certains leaders,
qui sont assez peu nombreux,
mais qui n'hésitent pas
à aller très loin,
il faut être
effectivement très ferme
et la loi de 1905,
il a raison de la rappeler,
ne faut-il pas inscrire le principe
de laïcité,
je suis en discussion
avec Michel Taube,
que vous connaissez certainement,
qui voudrait inscrire plus fermement
le principe de laïcité
dans la Constitution française
et il faut effectivement
que les maires essaient d'être,
dans divers cas,
le plus intégrationniste
possible,
mais on peut pas demander
non plus aux maires de tout faire
parce qu'on a tendance,
dans ce pays où le pouvoir politique
est excessivement faible
et joue fréquemment sur la peur,
il a tendance à ne plus assumer
ses fonctions principales.
-Qui va les assumer ?
-Et la fonction d'intégration
est une fonction
fondamentale dès lors
qu'on accueille plein de monde,
sans doute trop de monde
en mélangeant tout,
les flux migratoires, économiques,
l'asile politique,
on mélange un peu tout,
et il faut bien évidemment
avoir à côté de ça,
on l'a jamais eue en France,
une grande politique
d'intégration.
Les maires y ont leur part,
mais c'est une responsabilité
de l'Etat.
-Sur cette question
du communautarisme,
comment vos études
la prennent en considération ?
-Je voudrais
faire revenir le débat
sur identités
et territoires en France.
On est tous porteurs
d'identités multiples,
ça a été dit d'ailleurs un peu
par le maire de Grenoble,
mais ce qui a été préalable
à l'identité nationale
si elle existe,
c'est l'identité territoriale.
Y a des identités territoriales
depuis très longtemps,
les Bretons, les Normands,
les Occitans,
qui continuent d'exister,
ces entités font la richesse
du territoire français
et de la République
dans sa diversité
avec des modes de vie
différents,
et encore aujourd'hui,
ça reste même
un outil de marketing territorial,
on voit les deux capitales
régionales en Occitanie
aujourd'hui,
Toulouse et Montpellier,
jouer de cette appartenance,
et donc je sais pas
s'il faut appeler ça
du communautarisme
car ça a une histoire
très longue,
une géographie, une économie,
une histoire parfois frontalière,
avec l'Espagne
et avec l'Allemagne,
du côté de Strasbourg
ou de l'Alsace.
Ces communautés existent
culturellement,
de fait, et il faut pas
considérer que c'est mauvais
d'avoir des communautés différentes.
On a glissé un peu vite
sur les questions
d'extrémismes communautaires,
que vous dites d'ordre religieux
mais, à mon avis,
ça résume pas, disons,
le sentiment d'identité,
ou d'appartenance
aux territoires français.
Par ailleurs,
je voudrais revenir
sur cette idée
d'identité territoriale.
Comme vous le disiez,
y a eu des Parisiens
se disant bretons, auvergnats,
qui tenaient des cafés,
on a toujours
considéré qu'il était
possible d'être à la fois parisien
et breton ou auvergnat ou alsacien.
Je vois pas pourquoi
on pourrait pas continuer
de considérer que, en République,
y a un certain nombre
d'identités,
face auxquelles
on se trouve, typiquement,
quand on est à l'étranger,
on a jamais été aussi français
qu'à l'étranger et quelle que soit
notre appartenance multiple
à une religion, une communauté...
-Mais aujourd'hui,
on a des fractures identitaires.
Donc, la France,
c'est vrai que c'est
un territoire pluriel,
mais il y a, Juliette Méadel,
des fractures identitaires,
il y a des fractures communautaires,
elles sont politiques,
culturelles, socio-religieuses,
communautaires.
Comment vous pensez qu'on peut
tisser quelque chose entre tout ça
pour, quand même, fabriquer
un peu d'identité commune ?
-Je pense que l'histoire de France
s'est construite
dans un tissage permanent
d'apports, de sociétés,
de personnes qui venaient
de pays différents.
Là, on a une pression migratoire
plus importante que ce qu'on a connu
même en début de siècle,
donc il faut qu'on arrive
à tisser mieux cet espèce de...
de châle, on pourrait dire,
qu'est notre pays.
Y a quand même une particularité
que nous vivons
depuis à peu près
le début des années 80,
c'est que nous sommes
traversés par des mouvements
qui sont soutenus
par des, typiquement,
par des groupes
qui nous sont hostiles,
et je pense évidemment
à tous ces groupes
qui entretiennent
l'idéologie salafiste,
entretiennent
l'islamisme fondamental
à des fins politiques.
Je mets pas du tout
dans le même panier
ceux qui ont une pratique
religieuse...
-Personne ne met en cause l'islam.
-Non, il faut le redire
car j'ai entendu beaucoup
de politiques dire,
je cite : y a un problème
avec l'islam.
Non, y a pas un problème
avec l'islam,
y a un problème
avec l'islamisme fondamental
et tous ces mouvements qui sont
en ce moment en train
de se structurer,
comme dans les universités,
j'ai discuté avec un président
d'université
ce matin qui me racontait qu'il y a
des jeunes filles
qui sont, qui arrivent,
ostensiblement,
du jour au lendemain,
avec une burqa, un avocat,
et qui commencent
à vouloir perturber l'organisation
de la fac à des fins politiques.
Donc je pense que, là-dessus...
-Nous avons,
ici, dans des émissions,
dénoncé ce wokisme communautaire.
-Alors, les outils,
comment on fait ?
-Mais la tresse,
la tresse politique,
si vous voulez.
-C'est la République.
Clemenceau l'a bien dit,
c'est simple, liberté,
égalité, fraternité,
laïcité, évidemment,
tout ça doit s'apprendre,
se diffuser, se partager.
Au-delà la lutte contre
les mouvements sectaires,
à visée terroriste,
qui doit être fait par l'Intérieur
et par la Justice,
au-delà de ça qui doit être géré
par l'Intérieur et la Justice,
eh bien c'est un travail
d'éducation permanent.
Il faut faire en sorte
que le projet,
notre projet,
la nation démocratique
à la Ernest Renan,
soit partagé par tous.
Moi, je sais pas comment
on peut accueillir
si on n'arrive pas à faire
partager notre projet,
si on n'arrive pas
à mettre du service public partout,
dans tous les territoires.
C'est l'intérêt
de votre émission.
Je comprends pas
la diagonale du vide,
des zones de désertification
médicale qui sont telles
que les gens votent RN
car ils paient des impôts
sans avoir aucun
accès à un médecin.
C'est ça, l'enjeu de demain,
c'est du service public
partout sur le territoire,
qu'on habite
Paris, Montrouge ou la Creuse.
-Eric Piolle veut réagir,
vous vouliez réagir,
Eric Piolle.
-Oui, je voulais réagir
sur deux choses,
puisque j'ai entendu
Jean-Pierre Lecoq dire
qu'il voulait mettre la laïcité
dans la Constitution,
bon, c'est l'un des premiers mots
de la Constitution française,
l'article 1er : la République
est indivisible, laïque,
démocratique et sociale.
Donc que faire de plus
dans la Constitution
que d'inscrire ce principe
dès les premiers mots ?
C'est le deuxième mot
porteur de sens.
Donc c'est compliqué.
Mais cet article 1er
continue en disant
que l'organisation de la France
est décentralisée.
Et c'est pas ce que nous vivons.
Ce que nous vivons,
c'est qu'il y a une concentration
des pouvoirs à Paris,
évidemment,
des prises de décision à Paris
et que nous vivons,
depuis 2014, un revirement,
il y a eu un mouvement
de décentralisation
pendant une trentaine d'années,
de 82 à 2014,
pour faire simple,
et que derrière,
nous avons vécu trois ans
du gouvernement de Manuel Valls
puis, encore plus fortement,
cinq ans déjà de macronisme,
avec une recentralisation
des pouvoirs.
Et donc ça, partout en France,
évidemment, ça se sent,
on voit que les financements
ne sont plus
des prélèvements d'impôts locaux
mais deviennent des dotations
de Paris qui, dans sa "magnénitude",
nous lance quelques
millions d'euros.
Et donc, tout ça a évidemment
des conséquences
et donc, la réaction à ça,
c'est effectivement
que les territoires, chacun,
viennent se réancrer
dans une histoire plus locale,
pour nous le Dauphiné,
pour les Occitans,
pour les Basques
parce qu'il faut retrouver du sens
là où Paris est en train
de nous sucer le sang.
-On vous a entendu,
monsieur Piolle.
Je vais demander
à Jacques Lévy :
pourquoi, aujourd'hui,
Jacques Lévy, dire :
la République, toute la République,
que la République,
ça ne suffit pas à créer
ce liant national ?
Il faut bien le constater.
-Oui, parce que,
en fait, pour reprendre
votre question de tout à l'heure,
qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec les communautés ?
Les communautés, globalement,
à l'échelle mondiale et historique,
elles s'affaiblissent
parce qu'il y a l'individu
qui s'affranchit des communautés
et donc on assiste
à un combat titanesque,
je dirais, à l'échelle mondiale,
dont par exemple
la guerre en Ukraine
est aussi une expression.
Est-ce sur la base
du nationalisme,
qui est un communautarisme,
le plus sanglant de tous,
ou bien est-ce sur la base
des valeurs
qu'on construit une société ?
On l'a aussi chez nous,
parce que personne n'a cité
le mot Europe,
mais ce qu'on est en train de vivre,
c'est l'invention
de ce que Habermas appelait
le patriotisme constitutionnel,
c'est-à-dire que
l'attachement à l'Europe,
il croît sur la base
d'une adhésion à des valeurs.
Alors que, ce que vous appelez
la République,
c'est-à-dire l'association
entre des valeurs et un Etat
particulier qui est la France,
c'est une espèce de mixte
entre une prétention
universaliste
mais aussi un particularisme
national et en fait,
la manière dont l'Etat français
arrivait à gérer
ces communautarismes territoriaux
ou religieux,
c'était parce
qu'il y avait la guerre,
parce qu'il y avait le nationalisme,
le sang qui faisait
que les Français
dans les tranchées,
ils parlaient pas la même langue
d'ailleurs en 1914,
pour la plupart,
mais ils avaient un destin
tragique commun.
Et ça, de toute façon, c'est fini.
-C'est pas fini parce qu'on a
peut-être un retour
de la guerre en Europe.
-Mais ça sera pas une guerre
de nationalisme ou impérialisme
contre nationalisme ou impérialisme.
Et comment on tisse aujourd'hui ?
D'abord on tisse
plusieurs niveaux,
y a pas que la France,
y a le niveau local
dont parlait Eric Piolle,
y a le niveau régional,
le niveau européen
et le niveau mondial parce que,
avec les enjeux de nature...
-Ecoutez, restons en France,
si vous voulez bien.
-Non, je crois pas qu'il faille
rester en France.
-Eric Piolle,
sur la question
des traditions,
les traditions vont
avec la modernité
et vont avec une actualisation
de la République.
On vous a fait le reproche,
ainsi qu'aux écologistes,
d'être contre
certaines traditions,
par exemple le sapin de Noël,
par exemple le foie gras,
on a proposé d'interdire
la corrida, la chasse, etc.
Quelle est votre position,
à vous, sur ces questions-là,
et est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est un faux procès
qu'on fait aux écologistes ?
-Sur cette seconde partie,
évidemment, c'est un faux procès,
mais ça, c'est un peu normal
car les écologistes qui,
jusqu'à présent,
étaient plutôt des contre-pouvoirs,
on les traitait comme de gentils
adolescents un peu turbulents,
maintenant qu'il y a revendication
d'accession au pouvoir,
local à Grenoble en 2014
et un peu partout en 2020,
national j'espère pour 2027,
évidemment que la confrontation
devient plus forte,
et donc, il y a tous ces préjugés...
-Oui, mais dites-nous
votre position
sur les traditions.
-Les traditions,
pour moi qui suis basco-béarnais,
pour moi, la transmission
est extrêmement importante,
mais après, les traditions,
ce n'est pas le conservatisme,
les traditions se réinterrogent.
-Oui, mais vous êtes
pour ou contre la chasse,
par exemple ?
Vous êtes pour ou contre,
sur la question de la chasse,
de la corrida, du foie gras,
de toutes ces histoires-là ?
Est-ce que ça fait
partie de la France ?
Est-ce qu'il y a pas
des traditions sur lesquelles
on peut passer, si vous voulez ?
-Non, la corrida,
c'est un bon exemple.
Je viens d'un pays de corrida,
j'allais aux arènes...
-Alors il faut les interdire
ou pas ?
-Oui, il faut les interdire.
La corrida,
j'ai évité le sujet longtemps,
si je peux me permettre
de m'exprimer
et finir mon propos.
-On a très peu de temps.
-Alors n'engagez pas
la discussion sur le sujet,
si vous n'écoutez pas ma réponse.
J'ai évité le sujet longtemps
parce que je venais
d'un pays de corrida,
mais de fait, la corrida,
aujourd'hui, n'a pas de sens,
il faut l'abroger, en France,
c'est une exception légale,
et il faut l'abroger.
Ca ne veut pas dire
que les traditions en général
sont mauvaises.
Comme toujours, il faut transmettre
et questionner nos traditions.
La tradition de ne pas avoir
le vote des femmes
n'était pas une bonne tradition.
-C'est pas la même chose,
la corrida et le vote des femmes,
le rapprochement est un peu osé.
-C'est pour dire que les traditions
ne sont pas immuables,
on questionne les traditions.
-Permettez que j'interroge aussi
nos autres intervenants
sur la place de la tradition.
On a peu de temps.
-Je suis pour le maintien
des traditions,
mais dans certains cas,
il faut les faire évoluer.
-C'est votre avis, Juliette Méadel ?
-Je pense qu'on a pas
à rejeter un principe
parce qu'il est traditionnel.
Le fait qu'il soit traditionnel
ne le disqualifie pas.
La laïcité est
une tradition française
depuis un certain nombre d'années
et je pense que c'est une bonne
tradition car c'est aussi
ce qui fait qu'on partage
des principes en commun
et c'est quand même aussi l'histoire
qui, à un certain moment,
qui permet de tisser ce lien.
Et donc vouloir toujours
tout bouleverser tout le temps
pour le bouleversement
n'est pas bon.
En revanche, ce qui relève
de mauvaises évolutions
et de mauvaises tendances,
et je pense évidemment
au machisme
et à la misogynie
qui infiltrent
les inconscients et qui d'ailleurs
peut conduire à rapprocher
l'abrogation de la corrida
avec la question du vote des femmes,
doit être combattu,
car ça relève de l'historique.
-Là, c'est une pique.
Vous, Hélène Peskine,
un exemple de mauvaise tradition ?
-Oh, je sais pas
si ça va me venir comme ça,
mais je pense qu'il faut se garder,
effectivement, de conservatisme.
Les traditions sont quand même
issues d'un contexte
et donc, dans un contexte donné,
là, on en a très peu parlé,
mais l'évolution des territoires
est liée au changement climatique,
l'érosion de la biodiversité,
les questions environnementales.
Et c'est pas impossible
de se dire qu'une tradition née
dans un environnement favorable,
la chasse ou le foie gras,
favorable parce qu'il y avait
une capacité
d'accès à l'alimentation
ou au gibier
qui était forte,
elle est plus aussi favorable
dans un monde où la biodiversité
est en train de s'éroder.
Je pense aussi qu'il faut
interroger les traditions
au regard de la société
dans laquelle on est, de ses défis,
j'ai pas d'exemple précis,
mais je suis convaincue
que c'est pas immuable,
une tradition.
Par contre, si on élargit
cette idée de tradition,
par exemple la gastronomie,
un Français à l'étranger
se sent très français
parce qu'il a, ancré en lui,
dans sa culture plus que peut-être
son identité, terme que je récuse
à l'échelle nationale,
des choses qui font partie
du quotidien
des Français,
peu importe leurs origines,
et qui sont très fortement ancrées.
-Aujourd'hui,
la société de consommation
consomme tout.
C'est Marx qui disait
qu'on en est même à consommer
des rêves.
Jacques Lévy,
vous qui avez beaucoup travaillé
sur la notion de justice spatiale,
qu'est-ce que signifie
cette fringale de nature,
de biodiversité,
contre laquelle
Bruno Latour s'est élevé
en disant qu'il fallait pas
consommer la nature,
mais qu'il fallait
habiter avec elle ?
-Oui, habiter la nature,
je pense que c'est un beau projet.
Habiter, c'est un projet humain,
c'est lié à l'humanité.
Donc je pense qu'on est en train
de vivre l'intégration
par les humains
de la responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la nature,
ce qui ne faisait pas partie
du tableau de bord jusqu'à
y a quelques décennies.
En revanche,
les tendances
à l'animisme,
à un nouveau type de religion,
immanente, où les fleuves,
les glaciers seraient
dotés de personnalités,
et notamment
de personnalité juridique,
là, c'est une bascule
un peu anti-humaniste
qui, à mon avis,
est un danger
pour le fait que les humains soient
responsables mais avec l'idée
d'accroître leur liberté.
La liberté
et la responsabilité vont de pair.
Et y a un courant actuellement,
particulièrement
chez les écologistes radicaux,
qui consiste à dire
que la responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la nature doit
diminuer notre liberté.
Donc ce sont des bifurcations
politiques non négligeables
et je pense que les sociétés vont
avoir à se prononcer sur ce débat.
-Vous partagez ce point de vue,
Hélène Peskine,
qu'il y a cette espèce de...
Les gens cherchent
à se goinfrer avec tout,
y compris avec la nature,
alors que c'est un élément
de liberté
et d'épanouissement ?
-Je dirais qu'on sort d'une période
où on a eu une relation
plutôt prédatrice
aux ressources et à la nature,
dans l'idée que ces ressources
étaient infinies.
On se rend compte que
non seulement elles sont finies
mais que, en plus,
elles se raréfient au point
qu'on devrait changer
de modèle de développement.
L'interaction plus grande
entre ce qui fait l'écosystème
vivant entre humains
et ce qu'on appelle non-humains,
j'aime pas beaucoup ce terme,
mais tout ce qui fait le vivant
et qui contribue à faire
fonctionner l'humanité
est plutôt une bonne chose.
Pour revenir à la question
identités et territoires,
c'est un mouvement qui va
vers mieux connaître
son territoire,
ses ressources locales,
qu'elles soient humaines,
des savoir-faire historiques
ou des ressources matérielles,
minières,
car ou rouvre des mines
pour être plus autonomes
sur les terres rares,
des ressources agricoles,
forestières
pour les puits de carbone
à proximité des villes.
Ce mouvement
vers une meilleure connaissance
de ce sur quoi on est assis
et comment on garantit que ce soit
dans la durée pérenne,
il est indispensable
face aux enjeux
du changement climatique.
-Eric Piolle,
on a très peu de temps,
chacun va dire un mot là-dessus,
quand vous vous réveillez le matin,
vous connaissez ce poème
"J'aime bien le bruit de l'oeuf dur
"cassé sur le comptoir d'étain",
de Prévert, si je me trompe pas,
vous, quand vous réveillez,
à Grenoble, c'est quoi ?
-Bah, j'ouvre la fenêtre.
Moi, j'ouvre la fenêtre
et je vois la montagne,
je me dis que c'est extraordinaire,
c'est un émerveillement quotidien
et, effectivement,
changer notre liberté,
en fait, le but n'est pas
de réduire notre liberté,
c'est de requestionner,
est-ce que la liberté,
c'est la liberté de se détruire
entre humains,
de détruire le vivant
ou est-ce qu'on va
retrouver de la liberté
dans un nouveau rapport
aux limites en redéfinissant,
comme le disait Bruno Latour,
ce qui est important pour nous,
ce qui ne l'est pas,
ce dont nous dépendons,
ce que nous sommes prêts à changer.
C'est ça qui m'intéresse,
en oubliant jamais
qu'il y a une affaire
de justice sociale majeure.
Il faut sécuriser le changement
de toute une partie
de la population qui a besoin
de sécurisation pour avancer.
-Tout à fait.
Jean-Pierre Lecoq,
votre bureau est face à l'une
des plus belles places de Paris.
-Face à la nouvelle cathédrale.
-La place Saint-Sulpice.
C'est quoi,
votre madeleine ?
-Ma madeleine,
c'est de regarder cette place,
qui est merveilleuse,
qui peut se comparer
à une place de village.
Mais je voulais donner un message
d'espoir et rappeler quand même
que la France est un pays
de territoires,
un pays où, néanmoins,
la nature est encore belle,
faut faire plus pour la préserver.
Nos villes ne sont pas gigantesques,
comme aux Etats-Unis, Paris,
c'est 2,2 millions d'habitants,
elle est très dense,
mais c'est pas gigantesque.
On accède à la nature facilement.
Il faut pas non plus
culpabiliser
de façon extrême.
On le sait très bien,
les grands pays polluants,
c'est l'Inde, la Chine,
c'est tous ces pays-là.
Et un mot sur les nuisances
sonores...
-Non, on a très peu de temps.
-Moins y aura
de nuisances sonores à Paris,
comme la qualité de l'air,
et les Parisiens
resteront
plus nombreux à Paris.
-Juliette Méadel, très vite,
votre petite musique
à la fois parisienne
et banlieusarde ?
-Ma petite musique de Montrougienne,
c'est que j'ai la chance de pouvoir
aller travailler à vélo
et, quand je traverse
le périph' pour rentrer,
je suis heureuse d'être
dans ma ville, plus calme,
comme vous le dites,
plus apaisante,
et je crois que tout le monde,
en France, mais dans le monde,
commence à partager cette idée
que la ressource naturelle
est rare
et qu'elle est précieuse.
Et donc je crois que ça irrigue...
-On va rester
sur cette notion de rareté
et de préciosité
concernant la nature.
Merci.
Alors, je vais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie,
ici, Jérôme Batout.
C'est un livre un peu manichéen
qui dit que la province
est vraiment
quelque chose qui a tous
les avantages aujourd'hui,
que Paris est un peu délaissée.
Je voudrais également vous signaler
cet ouvrage d'Hervé Le Bras.
Comment les gens votent,
sur quelle base
et si vous voulez comprendre
pourquoi l'abstention est grande
et pourquoi il y a quelques
votes anthropologiques,
eh bah, vous avez ici
pas mal de données.
Je voudrais signaler,
de Juliette Méadel,
"Un impérieux besoin d'agir",
en deux mots, c'est quoi,
ce besoin d'agir ?
Vous vous réveillez
le matin en vous disant
"il faut agir" ?
La puissance d'agir de Spinoza ?
-C'est un peu Spinoza,
c'est un peu Hirschman,
sur le bonheur que l'on tire
de l'action publique
et c'est surtout cette conviction
qu'on peut pas rester
les bras ballants devant
l'immensité des transformations
qu'on doit mettre en place,
moi depuis Montrouge,
mais j'ai pu le faire aussi
depuis le gouvernement.
-Je voudrais signaler,
d'Eric Piolle, "De l'espoir !
"Pour une République écologique".
Monsieur Piolle,
vous espérez que,
un jour, la France aura
une République écologique ?
-J'espère effectivement
que nous changerons
notre rapport au vivant
et qu'on cessera cette société
de prédation en retrouvant du sens,
question qui habite la jeunesse
et qui, petit à petit,
va nous habiter de plus en plus.
-Je voudrais signaler
cet ouvrage de Jacques Lévy.
On pourrait dire, aujourd'hui,
politique de la géographie,
tellement la géographie
est devenue indispensable ?
-Oui,
de plus en plus,
pour des raisons
du changement du monde,
effectivement,
la dimension géographique,
elle est de plus en plus patente,
parlante, notamment...
-Et vous diriez aussi qu'elle permet
de mieux comprendre l'histoire ?
-Oui.
-Tout à fait,
beh, on partage ce sentiment.
Alors, le PUCA...
publie de très nombreuses
publications.
Parmi les dernières,
je voudrais vous signaler
"Régénérer une petite ville
"sous double influence
métropolitaine",
alors c'est le cas
de Rive-de-Gier.
C'est où ?
-La banlieue de Saint-Etienne,
on va dire,
mais c'est aussi un peu
sous influence, évidemment,
de la métropole de Lyon,
dans une vallée très industrieuse,
historiquement minière,
qui a subi la désindustrialisation
et donc c'est le récit
d'une renaissance,
possible en tout cas
dans le contexte actuel
de cette petite ville.
-Et je voudrais également
signaler "La métropole
"géographique
et ses urbanismes",
donc une autre publication du PUCA.
Jean-Pierre Lecoq,
vous avez un livre à signaler ?
-J'ai commis un essai,
je vous l'ai pas amené,
en 2018, qui s'appelle
"Une certaine idée de Paris,"
un essai sur la gouvernance
de Paris et je peux vous dire que,
quatre ans après,
y a pas grand-chose à changer.
-Ca rappelle
"Une certaine idée de la France"
et peut-être quelque filiation
politique.
-Oui, absolument.
-Et je voudrais vous remercier,
mesdames, messieurs,
merci, monsieur le maire
de Grenoble, d'avoir été avec nous
depuis vos montagnes,
comme vous dites,
merci à l'équipe de LCP et,
avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous soumettre
cette pensée :
"La distance dans la proximité,
"la proximité
dans la distance !
"Voilà le paradoxe
qui règne aujourd'hui
"sur tous nos efforts
pour reprendre
"les héritages culturels du passé
pour les réactiver
"sur un monde actuel."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA